nous retrouvons marine qu'elle mais elle
est présidente de l'association oued
légal bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france alors expliquez nous quel
rôle joue l'europe
concrètement l'europe a un rôle
important en tant que partenaire
commercial les signaux qui sont envoyées
par l'europe sont évidemment des signaux
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences
graves on l'a vu par exemple l'année
dernière au moment où l'union européenne
a annoncé c'était au mois de juin 2019
avoir trouvé un accord commercial avec
avec janet wolfson euros avec les pays
du mercosur à l'époque emmanuel macron
s'était montré bienveillant annonçant
qu'il avait trouvé une clause afin de
contraindre le brésil de respecter les
engagements climatiques
et puis quelques mois après alors que
l'amazone hills était d'un coup embrasée
et on voit la corrélation très claire
entre justement le signal positif au
niveau commercial et l'embrasement de
l'amazonie la france a rétropédalé
justement sur l'engagement du mercosur
est ce que l'europe est au courant de la
situation est ce qu'elle est ce qu'il ya
une traçabilité des exportations ou bien
est-ce que par défaut elle est
responsable en partie de la
déforestation en amazonie très
clairement quand on participe par des
accords commerciaux à faciliter les
échanges
on sait exactement dans quelle direction
on va le problème c'est que là dans ce
rapport ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on parle de déforestation illégale
aujourd'hui il ya la fois la
déforestation aussi les gueules qui pose
un problème la différence entre les deux
elle tient un coup de tampon de
l'administration aujourd'hui les forêts
tropicales et notamment les forêts
amazoniennes sont celles qui stocke le
plus de co2 on sait que en europe si on
veut tenir nos engagements on a aussi un
bilan carbone induits du fait de
l'importation de produits liés à la
déforestation qu'elle soit légale ou
illégale donc si on veut prendre des
engagements en europe pour lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique pour tenir nos engagements
en matière de lutte contre le changement
climatique il va falloir absolument que
repose la question de la production et
notamment la production de viande et
d'autres matières agricoles sur notre
territoire européen pour limiter
justement la déforestation et l'impact
qu'on peut avoir justement en ayant des
échanges avec ces pays qui
malheureusement comme on le voit au
brésil ne respecte pas les engagements
climatiques la déforestation au brésil
qui a atteint un niveau record au
premier semestre 2020 en quoi est-ce que
la crise sanitaire a accéléré le
processus
malheureusement les comptes il ya des
crises telles que ce qu'on a vécu en ce
moment on voit bien que les contrôles
environnementaux passe après le reste
est donc effectivement on ya moins de
contrôles de la part de la police de
l'environnement au brésil il se pourrait
que ce soit lié à ça et on voit une
augmentation très claire du nombre de
surfaces déboisées par rapport à l'année
dernière
donc les signes ne sont pas bons d'où
l'intérêt aussi évidemment de se reposer
cette question de de relocaliser en
france pour avoir un meilleur 1 à une
meilleure année à vie et leur
surveillance tout simplement de nos
écosystèmes du bon fonctionnement de
notre de notre économie aussi c'est
important et des conséquences pour la
santé des humains puissent quand le sait
la déforestation et a pour conséquence
justement comme ce qu'on a vu en chine
le lait l'apparition de zoonoses avec le
contact avec ces espèces sauvages on
peut s'attendre à ce que la prochaine
justement à pandémie viennent du brésil
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions marine calme et
je rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'association wild légal